[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 78 l'bdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 10 mars les
travaux ont débuté pour le squir du
Beaufortain morpa près de 5000 m Carr
sont réaménagés pour permettre notamment
l'installation du nouvelle aire de jeu
pour les plus petits coût total des
travaux 600000 €. Stéphanie pra est
notre invité fil rouge pour cette
émission juriste à les membres du Centre
d'Information sur les Droits des femmes
et des familles des Yvelines nous
évoquerons notamment avec elle l'égalité
homm-femme et son évolution dans notre
société dans le reste de l'actualité
retour sur l'abattage d'un rhinoceros au
parc de toiri malheureuse victimes de
braconnier ou encore les différentes
pistes envisagées par la Région
Île-de-France pour multiplier ses
ressources pour les transports sur fond
d'une nouvelle hausse probable du passe
Navigo je vous le disais en titre à
morpa le quartier de laagot est en
pleine transformation les travaux de
réaménagement du square de Beaufor ont
débuté mi-février parmi les nouveautés
attendues des équipements sportifs mais
aussi environnementaux les détails avec
ce sujet de Camille amambert et Michael
et
midoro pour le printemps ces engins de
chantier laisseront place à un jardin le
squir de Beaufortin fait peau neuve
morpar et aménage cet espace de 4500 m
car en lieu de vie
intergénérationnelle ça rentre en
perspective de l'amélioration du cadre
de vie des morpasiens avec l'aménagement
d'air de jeu c'était demandé notamment
des aires de jeu de pour les plus de 1
an donc ça va satisfaire aussi des
assistantes maternelles par exemple avec
des appareils de fitness pour adultes
mais aussi pour les personnes âgées
voilà un parcours santé qui est très
important aussi pour nous pour voilà les
les morpagiens qui souhaitent faire du
sport boulodrome table de ping-pong mais
aussi un équipement développement
durable c'est six carrés potagers qui
seront mise à disposition des morpasiens
avec un bac de récupération d'eau pour
alimenter ces 6 carrés potagers coût
total des travaux 600000 € financés à 30
% par le Conseil départemental un
investissement nécessaire pour ce
quartier qui n'avait jamais connu de
transformation ici même a démarré les
premiers coups de pied de la
construction de la ville nouvelle dans
les années 60 sur la plaine de la Giot
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le quartier
de la giio et donc voilà c'est aussi un
un signe fort dans le cadre du
renouvellement urbain j'allais dire de
notre ville belleeville de morpa dans la
même dynamique le groupe scolaire de la
giio sera rénové pour la rentrée 2019
l'Esquire de Reay et de Ran devrait
suivre le même exemple en
dans le reste de l'actualité de
l'économie et les bons chiffres pour la
création d'entreprises en France plus de
500000 entreprises ont été créé l'an
passé soit une Haos de 5,5 % par rapport
à 2015 et parmi celle-ci près de 200000
sont notamment des micro-entreprises un
statut en vogue à 51 en Yveline le point
avec annl Langy et Nicolas
d'André ctherine Guy a créé sa marque
média et médiation une microentreprise
spécialisé dans l'édition du livre sur
la médiation en entreprise journaliste
salarié à temps partiel elle s'est
lancée dans l'auto-entrepreneuriat pour
la simplicité du statut juridique je
savais que si je vendais rien je pais
rien aucune charge et si je vendais je
payit des charges qui me paraissaiit
simple et normal les auteurs et les
lecteurs préachètent une certaine
quantité de livres ce qui me permet de
de d'avoir du cash pour pouvoir payer
mes fournisseurs
j'ai des revenus très variables avec
l'activité d'édition je vous dire ça
peut être 30 € 300 € 3000 € selon les
mois je paye mes charges je paye mes
fournisseurs je paye mes auteurs mais je
me paye pas encore moi-même dans son
projet Catherine Guy a été aidée par la
Maison de l'Entreprise de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline plusieurs types
d'accompagnement à travers des réunions
de sensibilisation et des rencontres
individuelles avec des experts un statut
attractif notamment à travers la
flexibilité du plafond du chiffre
d'affaires nous avons environ 600
créations d'entreprise sur le le secteur
de de 50 ans d' 600 créations par an et
sur ces 600 nous recensons environ 250
auto-entrepreneurs l'aut entrepreneuria
c'est quelque part une période d'cès et
l'objectif pour nombre d'entre eux de
ces autres entrepreneurs c'est à cour ou
moyen terme de développer une entreprise
dans un contexte juridique classique
plus de 13000 entreprises on été été
créé en 2016 dans le département des
Yvelines en moyenne 40 % d'entre elles
sont des
[Musique]
micro-entreprises l'actualité de cette
semaine a été marquée évidemment par la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes c'était mercredi sur le
département des ivelines et sur les
communes de l'agglomération de
nombreuses action étit organisé comme à
la préfecture de Versailles où une
matinée spéciale a permis d'interroger
la place des femmes dans le mond monde
culturel alors que celle-ci ne
représente que 1 % des compositeurs et 4
% des chefs d'orchestre écoutez sur ce
sujet l'une des artistes présentes pour
l'occasion la femme a aussi autant sa
place qu'un homme aussi bien au milieu
culturel et on a plein de choses à
partager il y a des femmes qui sont
bourré de talent qui ont plein de choses
à partager aujourd'hui à véhiculer et
c'est un moment aujourd'hui c'est un
beau moment pour montrer aujourd'hui et
pour présenter nos créations présenter
ce qu'on sait faire et ce qu'on veut
partager comme message dans le milieu de
la musique les hommes peut-être plus de
choses ont peut-être plus de temps les
femmes sont plus occupées à autre chose
en l'occurrence les enfants et cetera
machin donc moi je me dis qu'on peut
peut-être aller les deux c'est faisable
et en gérant son temps et surtout en y
croyant parce que si c'est une passion
faut y croire et il faut s'imposer quoi
qu'il en soit donc je pense que pour moi
la femme a tout aant sa place qu'un
homme dans le milieu culturel et pour
évoquer à présent cette très vaste
problématique de l'égalité hommes-femmes
et des droits des femmes Stéphanie pra
nous a rejoint en plateau bonsoir
bonsoir Stéphanie pra vous êtes juriste
et membre de la section départementale
du Centre d'Information sur les Droits
des femmes et des familles c'est une
association qui œuvre notamment pour
développer l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes plus largement expliquez-nous
un petit peu quelles sont vos missions
comment vous agissez concrètement avec
l'association au quotidien par quelles
actions alors déjà rappeler que le
Centre d'Information sur les Droits des
femmes et des familles est une
association indépendante qui a été créée
en 1982 nous avons donc 35 ans
d'existence et
d'expérience nous nous exerçons une
mission d'intérêt général pour l'accueil
et l'information du public et pour cela
nous avons un agrément du secrétariat
aux droits des femmes et à l'égalité
donc concrètement allez-y allez-y
excusez-moi j'allais vous couper
concrètement notre association est
composée uniquement de salariés donc pas
du tout de bénévoles nous sommes une
vingtaine de
salariés une grande partie des salariés
sont les juristes dont je fais partie
donc nous recevons les personnes et en
grande majorité des femmes dans nos
permanences tous nos lieux de permanence
qui sont
50 dans l'ensemble du département
l'année dernière nous avons reçu 11000
personnes qui venaient pour se
renseigner sur leurs droits et
d'ailleurs quand vous dites 11000
personnes c'est important de le préciser
c'est principalement des femmes mais pas
que évidemment les hommes peuvent aussi
venir se renseigner auès de vous entendu
bien entendu l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes ne peut se faire que
ensemble hein n nous sommes nous
recevons des hommes et des femmes mais
effectivement la majorité de notre
public est constitué des femmes FEM qui
viennent se renseigner sur leurs droits
l'autre domaine d'action du Centre
d'Information sur les Droits des femmes
et des familles à côté de l'accès au
droits et de l'aide aux victimes c'est
l'accompagnement individualisé vers
l'emploi donc nous avons une équipe de
conseillers en emploi qui reçoit les
femmes de façon individuelle mais
également pour celles qui en ont plus
besoin dans le cadre d'accompagnement
renforcé en groupe donc le but but c'est
de les accompagner vers l'autonomie par
l'accès à la formation et l'accès à
l'emploi donc vous êtes vraiment présent
sur de nombreux thématiques beaucoup de
domaines sur un peu tous les problèmes
qui peuvent exister dans dans dans la
vie de de tous les jours voilà alors le
le cœur de notre travail c'est
effectivement l'accès au droits et
l'aide aux victimes et l'accès à
l'emploi mais notre approche est globale
c'est-à-dire que si une personne par
exemple vient me voir pour me dire je
souhaite divorcer on va avoir une
discussion
plus élargies pour voir un petit peu
s'il y a d'autres problématiques
notamment s'il y a des problématiques de
violence s'il y a des problématiques
d'emploi parce que une personne qui va
divorcer peut ça peut entraîner d'autres
conséquences donc on a une approche un
peu
globale et de l'autre côté mes mes
collègues conseillers en emploi
également vont rechercher les freins à
l'emploi il y a vraiment pour le public
femme des situations spécifiques en
matière de droit et en matière
d'emploi des situations que seules les
femmes rencontre enfin majoritairement
les femmes rencontrent donc une personne
une femme en recherche d'emploi mais qui
a également une problématique de
violence une problématique financière
parce que la pension alimentaire n'est
pas versée et cetera donc tout ça doit
être balayé et au besoins nous
réorientons sur les collègues compétents
alors vous personnellement vous
travaillez sur le secteur de trappe et
de de saint-quenttin en Eveline est-ce
que sur ce secteur là il y a des
problématiques particulières est-ce que
ou alors c'est sur l'ensemble comme sur
l'ensemble du département et puis comme
sur l'ensemble de la France alors euh je
pourrais pas vous dire si les
problématiques sont particulières moi
tout ce que je peux vous dire par
rapport aux problématiques spécifiques
aux femmes euh en tant que juriste donc
les problématiques qu'elle rencontrent
dans le cadre du travail c'est très
souvent à l'occasion de la maternité euh
donc une grossesse qu on estenceinte on
on se fait virer clairement oui ou en
tout cas on rend compre de gros
problèmes avec une mise au placard alors
c'est pas bien sûr systématique les
personnes que nous voyons sont les
personnes qui ont des problèmes les
personnes qui n'ont pas de problèmes ne
viennent pas nous voir mais
effectivement la problématique liée au à
à l'arrivée d'un enfant va se poser pour
pour les femmes
euh avec les difficultés notamment pour
le retour après un congé parental une
absence prolongée du fait d'une ou
plusieurs naissances il y a vraiment des
problématiques
spécifiques en
matière en matière juridique oui les
violences faites aux femmes aujourd'hui
on sait que sur l'ensemble de la France
chaque
année 223000 femmes déclarent être
victime de violence dans le cadre du
couple seulement une partie d'entre ell
14 % déposeent plainte et donc vous vous
pouvez être cet intermédiaire qui
facilite peut-être même si c'est pas
vers vous qu'on va porter plainte mais
vous pouvez être un premier on va dire
maillon pour se libérer parler raconterr
bien sûr alors le mon action dans ce par
exemple si je reçois une personne qui se
déclare victime de violence dans le
cadre de son couple je vais déjà poser
les mots en termees juridique bien poser
que la personne est bien victime de
violence que elle est victime qu'elle
n'est pas responsable de cet état de
fait que c'est l'auteur des violences
qui est
responsable sou les FEM on ces
impressions là enfin les victime de
violence on cette impression d'être
coupable aussi beaucoup beaucoup se
sentent coupable se demandent pourquoi
elles en sont arrivés là pourquoi elles
sont victime de violence elle et pas une
autre elles ont dû faire quelque chose
non bien sûr que non donc déjà bien
poser les choses
qualifier d' au niveau pénal lesffet
voilà imamine gifle oui alors monsieur a
commis tel fait hein des violences
volontaires aggravées voilà et ensuite
orienter leur dire qu'est-ce que je peux
faire maintenant que sans forcer non
plus à si si la personne ne veut pas
porter plainte on va pas pousser aller
contre le le souit de la personneûr le
la le but c'est de favoriser l'autonomie
des
personnes cette autonomie ne peut se
faire que en connaissant ses droits si
on ne sait pas qu'on a des droits on ne
peut pas les faire valoir donc déjà
connaître ses droits et ensuite indiquer
voilà si vous faites ceci si vous allez
déposer plainte voilà comment ça va se
passer voilà le schéma de la procédure
si vous ne déposez pas
plainte voilà ce que vous pouvez malgré
tout faire plus plus généralement on va
élargir sur cette journée des des droits
des femmes un rapport de l'INC est sorti
la veille et on va grossièrement le
vulgariser mais il dit qu'en gros les
inégalités si elles sont toujours
nombreuses et présentes dans la société
française elles ont tendance quand même
à se diminuer vous avec votre expérience
ça fait 20 ans je crois que vous
travaillez au sein de l'association
est-ce que c'est c'est un constat aussi
que vous partagez sans être forcément
trop optimiste est-ce que ça va quand
même dans le bon sens je pourrais pas
dire ça parce que encore une fois dans
le cadre de mes permanences je reçois
des personnes qui ont des problèmes donc
moi de toute façon je reçois toujours
plus de monde chaque année toujours plus
de monde oui alors ça ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'il y a plus de problèm
ça veut dire que les gens sont plus
informés voilà les les personnes sont
informés du fait que ils peuvent aller
rencontrer des
juristes et puis il y a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup depuis une vingtaine
d'années des campagnes pour la lutte
contre les violences qui favorise la
parole qui incite effectivement ces
femmes à se déplacer pour se renseigner
il est très important de de comprendre
que il ne faut il ne s'agit pas de juger
les gens une personne qui qui va venir
dans nos permanences pour nous faire
part de des des des violences dont elle
est victime
c'est une victime et on n'est pas là
pour lui reprocher son inactivité par
exemple si cela fait 10 ans il y a toute
une tout un schéma des violences qui
explique le fait que oui cela fait 10
ans que les violences sont installées et
il est très difficile de s'en sortir
avec votre expérience je voudrais vous
faire réagir maintenant sur un chiffre
un chiffre qu'on retient souvent dans le
monde du travail aujourd'hui en France
en 2017 une femme à travail et
compétence égal gagne 25 % de moins
qu'un homme comment on peut encore
expliquer de tels chiffres aujourd'hui
en France c'est parce que c'est
historique et qu'on a encore du mal à
casser les barrièresou oui alors il y a
depuis les années 80 de nombreuses lois
euh pour lutter contre ces inégalités
euh l'ensemble du droit en France et
notamment le droit du travail euh
interdit les discriminations euh
diverses et notamment les
discriminations entre les hommes et les
femmes mais malgré tout euh il y a une
difficulté à euh appliquer ces pourquoi
parce que déjà vous avez cette
différence elle peut s'expliquer par le
fait que dans la la les femmes actives
une moindre part de femmes actives que
d'hommes accèd aux emplois les plus
qualifiés donc une femme qui travaille a
moins de chance qu'un homme d'accéder à
un emploi de cadre à l'autre bout de
l'échelle une femme qui travaille a
beaucoup plus de on va pas appeler ça
chance de risque d'être occupé dans un
emploi non qualifié qu'un homme le temps
partiel subit alors il y a des personnes
qui sont à temps partiel par choix mais
le temps partiel subi touche en énorme
majorité les femmes et non les hommes
merci Stéphanie Prat d'être venu en
plateau puis pour toutes ces ces
précisions ces informations précieuses
que vous nous avez donné pour plus
d'informations sur votre association on
peut se rendre sur le site internet
alors oui le le mieux est d'aller sur
notre page Facebook vous tapez CIDFF 78
et Facebook et vous vous tomberez sur
notre
pagep d'être venu en plateau et puis non
sans lien on enchaîne sur le reste de
l'actualité un autre secteur où les
inégalités hommes-femmes sont flagrantes
même si là aussi elles tendent à se
réduire c'est le sport de haut niveau ou
non cette semaine le vélodrome national
de 50 an éeline organisé sa deuxe
édition de l'événement elle à vélo une
soirée pour promouvoir le cyclisme
auprès des femmes notamment un reportage
de Mélanie
poket les premiers gestes sont hésitants
mais le staff de la Fédération Française
de Cyclisme prodique des conseils pour
sa deuxè édition els velo invité à
nouveau les femmes au Vélodrome je
trouve c'est une super idée ça permet de
se retrouver entre filles et de passer
aussi un bon moment c'est une belle
façon de célébrer la Journée de la Femme
et puis on a fait des jolies découvertes
notamment le vélo smoothie qu'on a
trouvé très sympa d'ailleurs on fait
déjà du vélo un peu de BMX de VTT là
c'était l'occasion de faire un baptême
PIST que j'avais jamais fait baptême
donc que Nathalie Simon ancienne
championne de planche à voile et
animatrice télé a elle-même testé génial
je suis montée
jusqu'au au-dessus du bleu en haut là
presque en haut et je pensais vraiment
pas quand je l'ai vu au tout début je
disais non mais je vais jamais y arriver
c'est pas possible j'étais un peu en
apné et ben si et je suis très très très
contente soirée entre filles mais avec
un but bien précis montrer que le
cyclisme se conjugue aussi au féminin
c'est la mission que s'est donné la
Fédération actuelle seulement 10 % des
licenciés sont des femmes on voit que le
3è sport pratiqué par les femmes à 33 %
c'est le cyclisme c'est le vélo au sens
large du terme toutes les pratiques VTT
routes ou d'autres donc il y a un
potentiel énorme en matière de de
développement et je pense que on va
pouvoir monter à 20 25 % de licencier
d'â au sein de la fédération c'est une
ambition et pour ça on s'est donné des
moyens des outils pour que nos club soit
aussi sensibilisé à l'ensemble des
pratiques un kit pédagogique sera
proposé au club dès le mois de join pour
donner des ailes au
vélo on poursuit ce tour de l'actualité
locale de la semaine avec de la
politique lundi le chef de l'État
François Hollande recevait à Versailles
les chefs de gouvernement européen
allemand espagnol et italien un mini
sommet européen à quelques semaines du
60e anniversaire du traité de Rome
durant ce rendez-vous François Hollande
a notamment plaidé pour une plus grande
collaboration en matière de défense et
une Europe à plusieurs vitesses mardi
c'était son ancien ministre de
l'Économie Emmanuel Macron qui était au
Mureau pour un déplacement de campagne
le candidat dans marche a visité un
groupe scolaire et développer quelques
points de son programme pour l'éducation
enfin à droite cette fois-ci la
contre-attaque et l'appel au
rassemblement sont lancés après
plusieurs semaines chaotique pour le
candidat Fillon plusieurs ténors du
parti étaient présents en réunion
publique mercredi soir à plaisir parmi
eux Valérie pcrè président de la région
î- de France David Douillet député des
ivlines ou encore Xavier Bertrand
président des haau de France
dans le reste de l'actualité une triste
première en début de semaine et en
pleine nuit des braconniers ont tué un
rhinocéros aux EAU DE toiri ils ont
aussi Sié la corne de l'animal une
première dans un tel lieu en Europe la
nouvelle a forcément bouleversé les
employés du parc retour sur cette
affaire avec Michel midero et Camille
Ambert ils ne sont plus que deux dans
leur enclos dans la nuit du lundi 6 mars
des braconniers ont abattu Vince 4 ans
l' des rhinocéros du parc de toirie
arrivé en 2015 sa corne a été sillée une
macabre découverte mardi par la
soigneuse principale aux alentours de
9h30 elle est arrivée à la maison des
Rino elle a constaté que le la porte
avait été fracturée qu'une autre porte à
l'intérieur de la maison avait été
fracturée et elle a trouvé donc le
malerino Vince mort dans son box on part
quand même du principe que les animaux
sont dans un parc zoologique sont
protégés justement du braconnage qu'on
rencontre dans la nature donc là c'est
très très choquant un choc pour l'équipe
mais aussi pour l'ensemble des parcs
animaliers c'est la première fois qu'un
tel événement se produit en Europe en
Afrique du Sud le braconnage de
rhinoceros a connu une hausse
considérable ces dernières années en
2015 1175 rhinoceros blanc ont été tués
pour leur cornes contre 13 en 2007 il y
a myth autour de la corne de Rino qui
est absolument pas fondé he
scientifiquement mais il y a des
personnes qui croient que c'est
aphrodicia que c'est une cure contre le
cancer alors que enfin pas du tout c'est
c'est comme de la kératine c'est comme
les cheveux c'est comme les ongles sur
le marché noir 1 kg de corne peut-être
vendu 50000 € le parc est équipé de
caméas de surveillance selon sa
directrice les individus connaissaient
les lieux le domaine de toirvaporter
plainte une enquête est
ouverte c'est une problématique
essentielle pour le développement de la
région Île-de-France comment financer
les futurs investissements dans les
transports en commun expert et politiqu
é réuni mardi matin à Paris à
l'initiative du syndicat des transport
d'Île-de-France pour justement discuter
de cette thématique un enjeu majeur
alors que les sources de financement
classiques se tarissent quand les
investissement souhaités eux
augmentent des trains plus efficaces des
rames plus moderne à une sécurité
renforcée les ambitions portées par le
STIF et la région Île-deFrance sont
élevées pour les transports en commun
francilien mais alors comment les
financer d'ici 2030 plus de 20 milliards
d'euros d'investissement sont prévus
nouveaux matériels roulant nouvelles
lignes comme le tram 13 dans les Yveline
ou encore le Grand Paris Express il faut
donc trouver des ressources
supplémentaires qui pourraient déboucher
sur une nouvelle hausse de la
tarification pour les voyageur ça fait
15 ans que chaque année en moyenne à 2,5
% le Pass Navigo ou la carte orange
ament donc c'est pas un sujet nouveau et
oui il continuura naturellement
d'augmenter la présidente s'est engagée
à ce qu'il n'augmente ce qui est pas ce
qui un changement avec ce qui se passait
avant estce qu'il n'augmente qu'avec de
l'offre supplémentaire cette année il a
augmenté enfin l'année dernière il a
augmenté de 3 € nous avons eu de l'offre
supplémentaire en contrepartie c'est ça
l'engagement politique qui est pris par
la présidente autre solution envisagé
pour disposer de nouvelles recettes des
tarifs plus élevés pour les touristes
l'instauration d'heur creuse ou d'heur
pleines ou encore la mise à contribution
des automobilistes via un page urbain à
l'instar du modèle britannique on oublie
de dire que sur les millions de
déplacements quotidiens en
Île-de-France pratiquement 60 % se font
aujourd'hui en automobile donc il faut
prendre au sérieux l'automobile
peut-être investir sur la voirie dans
certaines zones et symétriquement
demander à ces automobilistes de
contribuer d'autant que ces
contributions du type péage de
congestion ou péage en période de
pollution c'est aussi un moyen de rendre
la mobilité plus durable un londonien
peut débourser jusqu'à 415 € par mois
pour ses déplacements transport en
commun contre 73 € jusqu'à présent avec
le passe Navigo pour un Parisien c'est
official depuis plusieurs semaines les
cinémas sirano et Roxan de Versailles
passe sous le giron du groupe UGC un
rapprochement qui devrait permettre de
de rénover les salles excusez-moi et de
proposer aussi une offre plus moderne
aux clients les précisions de Camille
amambert le CIRANO de Versailles aux
couleur du GC c'est une nouveauté depuis
début 2017 le Grou group à racheter la
salle en décembre il s'est associé à
Marie lorcouer nièce de l'ancien
propriétaire des lieux un partenariat
établi sous la société les cinéma de
l'Ouest ce cinéma pour moi c'est le
cinéma de mes grands-parents de mon
oncle et même de mes arrières
grands-parents donc ce qui était c'était
important pour moi que ce que ça reste
un un patrimoine familial mon grand-père
a longtemps dirigé l'UGC a travaillé
longtemps avec le président actuel et
quelque part je j'y retrouve mes valeurs
également voilà donc c'était un choix
assez naturel pour moi euh de de choisir
ce partenaire- là UGC a pour mission
d'assurer la gestion et la rénovation
des salles le cinéma sera rendu plus
accessible aux personnes à mobilité
réduite des travaux ont déjà eu lieu
dans l'accueil pour le moderniser c'est
une restructuration lourde toutes les
salles seront concernées par la par le
projet l'ambition si vous voulez très
clairement c'est de faire du Cano
j'allais dire un cinéma de référence du
centre-ville de Versailles donc c'est un
cinéma qui a une histoire c'est un
cinéma qui a un nom qui qui qui a une
forte notoriété finalement ce sera un
cinéma UGC avec une enseigne UGC et puis
la carte liimitée tout enfin tout leur
savoir-faire au niveau de la
programmation le groupe souhaite donner
plus d'importance à la version originale
pour les habitués UGC se veut rassurant
il s'engage à conserver le caractère
généraliste et de proximité du
cierano fin de ce 78 lebdo merci de nous
avoir suivi nos reportages sont en
revoir dès à présent en replay sur notre
site Inter TVfil 78.com ou l'application
TVfil 78 merci de nous avoir suivi et à
la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine